[Musik]
warum gehen wir nicht öfter angel möchte
mal wieder in fisch essen in sich selbst
gefangen hat bitte nicht wieso bitte
nicht wir waren bestimmt zehnmal angeln
und wir haben ein fisch gefangen ja aber
der fisch war groß und er hat
fürchterlich geschmeckt
wir sind ganz furchtbar wir sind eine
furchtbare fußballer fast stimmt doch
überhaupt gar nicht nico ihr seid sehr
schlechte fußballer
ich will mich gar nicht in der sitze
spieler erinnern es ist mit volleyballer
ihr könntet volleyball spielen ich liebe
wohl okay sagen wir nicht alle hassen
volleyball aber nur wenige mögen wollen
okay was ist mir breit machen pferde
reiten
wie soll ich das machen werde ist doch
bestimmt einen breit verein in der nähe
ja und nein ich mag pferde aber ich kann
nicht rein und ich möchte es auch nicht
gerade
ich sag ja nur wir könnten wieder mal
was zusammen machen
du kannst gleich wieder gehen können wir
reden niko gibt mir eine chance ich
möchte dass du mir wenigstens zuhörst
ich glaube du hast gestern schon alles
gesagt
er ist ein bruder nico werde jedoch
wenigstens einmal an was ihr sagen
möchte